المحيط الهادئ يقبل على مرحله جديده من
المواجهه وهو الذي يضم اكثر من منطقه توتر
بعد اعلان طوكيو مراجعه سياستها الدفاعيه
ووضع خطه جديده لمواجهه بيكن والتصدي لما
تصفه بنفوض الصين العسكري الخطه اليابانيه
تعتزم زياده ميزانيه الدفاع السنويه من
واحد الى اثنين بالمئه من اجمالي ناتج
المحلي بحلول 2027 وزياده مدى الصواريخ
السياسه الدفاعيه اليابانيه تشير بوضوح
الى الصين باعتبارها تحديا امنيا غير
مسبوق بالاضافه الى كوريا الشماليه وروسيا
وتعتمد لهجه اكثر صرامه من ما كانت عليه
في العام 2013
الامنيه المختلفه التي تواجهها اليابان
نحن في نقطه تحول تاريخيا البيت الابيض لم
يتاخر لاعلان دعم الخطه التي اعتبرها
جريئه وتاريخيه لتعزيز الدفاع عن منطقه
المحيطين الهندي والهادئ خطوه اليابان
اثاره استياء ثاني اقوى اقتصاد في العالم
الصين التي تمتلك احد اكبر الجيوش اتهمت
اليابان بتشويه سمعتها وتجاهل الحقائق
والابتعاد عن التفاهمات
في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادي وخارجها
اليابان تتجاهل الح وتبتعد عن التفاهمات
والعلاقات الثنائيه معنا وتشوه سمعه الصين
نحن نعرض ذلك بشده
استراتيجيه اليابان الجديده التي تتحدث عن
خطر صيني جدي تشير ايضا الى كوريا
الشماليه القوه النوويه في المنطقه ستزيد
الاوضاع المشحونه اصلا وتعزز مخاطر التوتر
في المحيط الهادئ بلال الوجداني العربيه